hales of guys my name is a Chino and
welcome to came programming season 2 so
game programming has been going on for a
while it's been almost four years we've
got 125 episodes up it's a huge show and
I thought with the end of the
civilization series which is I'm going
to talk more about that as well here it
would be a good as good as time as ever
to actually make this into a season to
kind of thing let's have a break in the
game programming series and let's let's
start off kind of fresh with season two
right obviously by start off fresh I
don't mean let's start a gun or anything
we're going to keep keep working on it
obviously we're not going to abandon the
project or anything we're just going to
kind of open up a new chapter in game in
game programming to start kind of fresh
almost i might even mix up the format
but we will obviously be continuing
making rain so let's talk about the sir
ization series for those of you who
don't know and i know that there are a
lot of you because i have gotten tweets
and comments and everything for the past
few months being like hey when's the
next episode of game programming coming
out why aren't you posting game
programming videos i basically have been
right if you haven't noticed there is a
series on this channel called
civilization okay and these
serialization series is actually part of
game programming right you need to watch
those videos there'll be a link in the
description that also be an annotation
on the screen right now which will take
you to the playlist for that series
there are 16 episodes it just finished
last night that was the last episode
right that series is basically for game
programming right so what I mean by that
is rather than actually call it like
game programming episode 126 and stuff I
wanted to kind of start it as a fresh
project because we still need to do the
work with the sterilization stuff right
I wanted to started as a fresh project
so the people who weren't watching
canberra gramming could also follow
along right I didn't want to make game
programming a dependency for that series
because it really isn't a dependency at
all but that code is going to be copied
and pasted into game programming right
we made the rain cloud sterilization
library in that series we're going to
literally
make a new project in our Eclipse
workspace called rain cloud and then
just tie in rain with that project so
you need to watch those videos if you
want to know how this works right very
very important that you do that so I'm
sure that a lot of you will see this
video because it will be titled like
game programming season 2 you'll be like
oh let's game programming I'll watch
this and then you'll be like Oh what the
civilization series with all about that
well I'm going to go and wash it so yes
you should watch it you should watch it
because we're probably going to return
back to game programming season 2
episode 1 next week sometime maybe the
week after so it's going to come up soon
so you need to review that series this
is the first thing I want to mention so
we will be integrating rain cloud into
rain over the next episode right and
that'll be really easy by the way all of
the code for rain cloud is actually on
github as well and if you follow the
series you'll see that so like that part
is totally up on github and you can grab
it if you like but anyway that part we
will be putting into into our into our
project okay so that's that's the next
order of business for game programming
that's what we're going to kick off
season two with and then after that
we're going to continue on with
multiplayer so we started off website
125 was about preparing for multiplayer
and we kind of do very minor of
factoring and we kind of just got ready
for it but of course the major thing
that we needed was some kind of some
kind of sterilization library or a way
to serialized data so that we could both
send it and receive it from the network
or to the network right so now that
we've got that library that we wrote
which is in the serialization series so
you need to watch the serialization
series that library rain cloud is what
we're going to use okay so really the
next kind of the next major thing we're
going to work on in game programming is
going to be multiplayer we're going to
learn about how we can use sockets and
really how network communication is
going to work how we can send and
receive data via the network right
between two computers in between a
server and a client that I expects going
to take anywhere from 10 10 to 20
episodes maybe I actually don't know
I've done zero planning for it and i
really don't intend to do planning all
the planning will be done
the actual series so not sure how long
it'll take but that that's going to be
the next order of business now my
question is once multiplayer is done
right and multiplayer of course isn't
really going to be like what i mean by
implement multiplayer i don't mean like
fully make the game work with
multiplayer right because we don't know
what multiplayer is the game has no
gameplay really yet right so by
multiplier I just mean let's set
everything up so that we can now handle
multiple clients and we can get and we
can get two players to connect right the
actual interaction between two players
or something that is all gameplay stuff
and that will be done later but getting
that multiplier kind of foundation so
that we can actually use the network to
communicate between two devices to
computers that's what that's what that's
what the multiplayer kind of components
going to focus on so after that I don't
know what you guys want okay game
programming is a very old series I don't
know how many people follow it i know
that actually a surprising amount of
people follow it for how long it's been
going for right and there are probably
new people every day who find it so i
know that it does have quite a large
following so i do want to ask you guys
what is it that you want to see right
what exactly is this game that we're
making like I'm happy to be like you
know what let's focus on actually making
this a game that we can release for the
community yeah if that's the direction
that you want me to take it then I'll do
that right I'll focus on actually
designing a game rather than teaching a
lot of the concepts right as in what I
mean is like i'll still be obviously
narrating myself as i typed the code and
everything it's just not going to be all
about hey let's cover all of our bases
for game programming which is kind of
what the previous hundred episodes were
all about right i did i did a little bit
of everything yeah whereas here i'm
saying maybe it's time to actually sit
down and get some core gameplay in and
actually make this a game that we can
play right the second question is a lot
of people have been begging me hey you
should convert this to use lightweight
you have a game library or you should
use up in jail you should rewrite the
series and save plus plus obviously I'm
not going to do that it's going to take
way too much time but anyway the point
is is that something you're interested
in right
should i do any of that it's again up to
you I have so to speak given up control
of the series to you guys because it's
not something that I really want to
spend time planning I'm happy to keep
making episodes for it and that's
totally okay I like doing that but I
don't really want to sit down and be
like this is what I'm going to focus my
time on right because of course like
Sparky for example a sparky engine if
you guys aren't following that series of
course very very important that you do
because it's it's awesome there anyway
but like the Sparky engine is kind of
where most of my time's going anyway but
with the game programming series I'm
kind of opening it up to you guys I want
the community to decide exactly what
should be done with that series which is
why I'm kind of starting this quaint
clean slate with season two and I'm
saying hey guys like what would what do
you want to see ya let's kind of let's
probably make some kind of came out of
this so we can wrap up the series so
that we can satisfy everyone so that we
can so that we can really like tie this
up and tie it tie this up nicely and
call it a complete series on game
programming right because that's really
what it's about so that's my question
it's just this is going to be a
discussion i'm going to try and reply to
as many comments as i can but that is my
kind of plan for season two I really
think the series deserve is like a
little bit of a reboot in terms of
direction because it's kind of been
lacking that and I've kind of been just
Garrett like previously I was just
looking at the comments being like okay
people asking for multiplier I guess
I'll do that and it's been a bit it's
been a bit dodgy like if you actually
watch this here if you look at this
series contextually and you actually
look at what has happened it's very kind
of up and down it's very it's very
abrupt like there'll be some things like
one day we'll be working on collision
then we'll be working on something else
and it's just it's really all over the
place and I'm at the moment I'm not even
sure if I'm really helping people learn
that much so your feedback is going to
be important for game programming
because as I said it's something that I
do want to be completely hundred percent
community driven so yeah thatthat's
that's pretty much all i have to say if
you guys enjoy this video then please
hit the like button also if you if you
actually if you want the source code to
game programming then you can actually
head over to my patreon patreon.com for
the chur know and if you pledge five
dollars or more per month which is like
I mean five bucks a month is really what
is that it's like it's like half a lunch
or something right if you pledge that
March you will get an you will get
access to the github repository for all
of the game programming source code so
you'll have all of the source code there
ready to go for season two so if that is
something you're interested in and of
course not only will that help you but
that will also help me a lot as well so
if it is something you weren't
interested in then they'll be a link in
the description below it's completely
optional you don't have to do it it's
just that if you do want the source code
that is an option that is available to
you alright guys leave your feedback
below and I'll see you next time goodbye